as has always been the case the UK will
play a leading role Britain a global
include a military power a financial hub
and now brexit but is brexit changing
the way the rest of europe views britain
for some this disappointment to british
voice on in international affairs will
certainly be diminished for others a
loss of faith you would expect a country
that has run an empire to be able to do
planning one two or five years ahead and
there are those who still see greatness
I cannot imagine that their future is
not bright
[Music]
I'm going on a journey to four European
countries to find out if people's
opinion of Britain is being affected by
brexit the Netherlands one of Britain's
closest allies in Europe and a vital
trading partner Britain is the third
biggest destination for Dutch exports
with the Port of Rotterdam a key gateway
for goods thousands of crates of fresh
fruit and vegetables are loaded onto
lorries bound for British supermarkets
everyday Britain is still seen as an
economic power here but concern about
red tape at once frictionless borders
hangs heavy the whole brexit makes us
feel quite frustrated the way how the
brexit is currently developing that's
that's something that's frustrating for
us because we really have very limited
information and we need to prepare our
whole business with that limited
information
it takes about three and a half hours to
offload and reload one of these giant
ferries but the potential introduction
of customs checks after brexit would
cause delays
from the viewpoint of this passenger
ferry you can get a sense of the scale
of operations for a port that sends
Freight around the world any disruption
to the flow of goods with Britain could
impact on produce heading elsewhere so
the sense of worry at this port because
of the added administrative burden
brexit will bring but more profoundly
there's a sense of sadness and loss as
an invisible barrier falls on these
shores between the Netherlands and what
has been an open gateway to the UK in
The Hague there's an acceptance of
Britain's decision to leave the European
Union but disbelief at how the British
government has handled preparations for
brexit the failure to finalize a
withdrawal agreement is causing a
headache for politicians as they
struggle to get ready in case of a No
Deal
Peter upset is the chief brexit planner
in the Dutch parliament what does it
make you think of Britain the fact that
we're in this situation
you would expect a country that has run
an empire to be able to do planning one
two or five years ahead because that's
what you did when you had an empire and
now before a crucial day are only two
months left and we still haven't take
taken the decision let alone do the
implementation leaving Dutch
exasperation behind I gauged the mood in
next-door Germany Europe's largest
economy and the country increasingly
charged with shaping the --use future
alongside France as Britain heads for
the exit politicians at the German
parliament have a sinking feeling about
the UK some even wrote an open letter in
The Times appealing for a rethink I
would be very very sad
I do politically consider this to be a
huge damage both to Britain and to
Europe what makes you like Britain the
most what's most important to you what
we have Europe and the European Union
without Britain having fought for the
survival of Europe so it starts with it
starts with history in your new opinion
of Britain as a country Britain as a
leading nation has that changed in a way
I would say firstly in a way we all as
Western
is share more or less the same illness
we have rx-8 you have Trump you have
nationalism populism and all of that on
the one side on the other side of course
what we have seen in the past is a
leading Britain to be rational pragmatic
and now we see a Britain which is self
absorbed by a self-inflicted political
tactical power struggle so do you think
therefore like up until now that the
Britain has been able to really drive
its agenda or within the EU and do you
think now it's going to find it much
harder to get the eu-27 to listen to its
priorities than it did when it was part
of the club
certainly the British voice on in
International Affairs will certainly be
diminished Germany's loathing of brexit
is in part because it also makes the EU
weaker and the burden on Berlin greater
to keep European unity at a time of
heightened risk this means they'll still
be a need to work with Britain on global
issues Estonia where the temperatures
colder but the attitude towards Britain
appears a little warmer security is a
particular priority here given the
country's shared border with Russia
at the Estonian Naval Base in Tallinn a
band is practicing
well aboard this mine hunter sailors are
ready for action today's drill how to
deal with a fire britain operates the
same class of mine hunter as the
Estonians a sign of their close ties do
you get to work with other countries
such as Britain yeah of course we are
going in April to UK and there we are
gonna upgrade our ship one of the newer
members of the European Union this boat
sixth eighth sees the block as a vital
part of its security along with NATO the
Foreign Minister is diplomatic when
asked for his views on Britain and
brexit I'm not happy about the UK
leaving and I don't think that it's it's
gonna strengthen the position of the UK
in in global affairs
I don't think it's gonna strengthen the
ability of the EU to play a role in the
global affairs but I think that we are
able to come together bu and and and the
UK in here is that that really matter in
their security on security since the
truly matter of hundreds of British
troops are in Estonia as part of a NATO
mission to deter Russian aggression here
in Tallinn
officials are putting on a brave face in
public expressing confidence that brexit
won't affect the UK's input on shared
security challenges such as the one
posed by Russia privately however some
admit that things are changing for exit
is on occasion diverting Britain's
attention away from other issues and the
voice of a country this only in NATO as
opposed to being in NATO and the
European Union does have a different
impact especially when dealing with a
security threat that needs a military
and a political response
a 20-minute drive outside Tallinn is the
home of Burdett a married mother of two
young girls who works as a forensic
scientist and in her free time is part
of a volunteer Women's Defense Force and
here's my you like ready to go back here
it's like the uniform that I need to go
to first order shooting competitions or
she signed up out of a sense of duty to
her country which broke free of the
former Soviet Union when she was a
toddler but it says she feels safe but
the threat from Russia is real a few
times a year when there's news that
hundreds of thousands of Russian troops
are like 20 kilometres behind the border
exercising with their army maneuvers
then it's scary it's quite scary because
we know that Russians are not very
stable and what they say is not what
they do
she seems worried about the EU losing a
big member state Great Britain has been
always throughout the history if they
have been supporting this little country
here so I think it's an ally that I do
hope somehow they're good relations stay
as I leave Estonia I feel Britain's
reputation as a security partner remains
intact despite the undeniable sense of
uncertainty a different kind of Island
Switzerland is surrounded by the
European Union but isn't part of the
block and offers a different perspective
on Britain and its future at this
boutique watchmaking shop in zurich life
rotates around precision and attention
to detail producing two watches a day
for sale anywhere in the world
the owner says trading with the EU is no
hassle do you look differently at the
United Kingdom because of the decision
is missing in what way how's your
opinion changed because we watch what's
going on
how will they solve Ireland problem we
need a strength versus a Russia versus
United States and now we have internal
problems it's not good and do you think
the UK and Switzerland will become
closer Ally
maybe maybe and is that a good thing of
course but who knows you know Prince
Charles is always in Switzerland always
scheming closest so I don't know who
else is coming
Switzerland is locked in its own tussle
with the EU over their future
relationship currently based on more
than 120 bilateral agreements this
former diplomat helped strike a number
of them
he believes Britain like his country can
thrive outside the Union has a
perception of what Britain is of who
Britain is has it changed at all over
this brexit decision not really I think
no what do you think of Britain when you
think Britain what do you think I think
the Brits as the Suites hazards have a
certain give a certain importance to
sovereignity question and have a bit the
safety system to rule taking and the
both of us are are in favor of free
trade but the future of Britain I'm
talking about not the brexit once brexit
is long distant memory is the future of
Britain rosy Great Britain is a big
European nation I cannot imagine that
their future is not bright
despite Swiss confidence views of
Britain are changing for the worse
in parts of Europe but there is one
unifying belief that the UK will remain
a valued ally
even after brexit day dawns